OK.
Now, this is sort of funny, but some people
are furious.
Why?
Because people are furious about everything
these days.
Bomb throwing.
Right wing radio host Rush Limbaugh quoted
me yesterday.
He actually read one of my tweets.
And it was one of the tweets I sent during
the stream of the first night of the Democratic
National Convention.
At the time, I didn't think it was going particularly
well because it wasn't.
So I'm going to play the clip of Rush for
you.
Then I will talk about the reaction from some
on the left to this and just how completely
misguided and and missing the boat.
Some people are about this.
Let's look at Rush's clip.
First, David Pakman political TV radio show
host tweeted, Someone please talk me off the
ledge.
I want to win the first 22 minutes of this
convention.
I'm scared.
Can somebody tell me how great this is or
something?
Can somebody make me feel better?
Didn't start well.
OK, so the exact tweet that he read, he added
a paraphrase at the end, which is Make me
feel better.
I didn't actually tweet that.
I tweeted.
22 minutes into night, one quote, someone
please talk me off the ledge.
I want to win.
And the first 22 minutes of this DNC, I'm
scared.
Can someone tell me how great this is or something?
Now, later on, it improved than I said it
did, particularly with Michelle Obama's speech
at the end of the night.
And 92 was significantly better than night
one overall.
But here's what I want to talk about with
you.
I mentioned earlier and yesterday.
That some people on the left were mad at me.
They were even furious at me.
I even had a few cancelations for lack of
a better term, because I was criticizing the
first part of night, one of the DNC, and there
were people on the left reacting with, you
know, this feeling of how does David have
the audacity to criticize what the DNC is
doing?
That I'm the problem because I'm pointing
out that I don't like some of this stuff and
I'm being mean and I'm not being supportive
of enough of removing Donald Trump or being
a team player or whatever.
That is exactly the B.S. garbage tone, policing,
gatekeeping nonsense that leads us to losing.
And some people said, David, when you tweeted
that you literally created fodder for the
right in the sense that Rush Limbaugh then
read your tweet.
But the DNC was not going well at that point
in time.
I didn't like what I saw.
The right was going to say it was terrible
no matter what.
So it wouldn't make a difference in that sense
because the right is going to come out and
say, this is terrible and what an embarrassment
and blah, blah, blah.
I said what I believed to be going on.
And you know what?
Later on it improved than I said.
So I'm not saying it improved because of what
I said, but who gains anything from me lying
to you and saying, wow, this is really great.
This is this is going so well.
And so when I see these comments, oh, you
ended up supporting Republican talking points
by tweeting that.
No, I reacted genuinely.
That's the promise.
That's the premise and the promise of this
program.
My commitment here is not always to say what
you think.
It's not to be onboard with whatever is the
orthodoxy of the Democratic Party.
I'm not even a Democrat.
Remember, the reason people watch the live
streams and the content is to get my honest
and immediate reactions to what's going on.
What do we gain if I do political theater
where I say, you know, this is crap, but it
would look bad if I say that.
So I'm going to pretend that this is great
and lie to my audience.
Like, is that actually what people are suggesting
I should do?
Because Rush Limbaugh read one of my tweets.
The fact that Limbaugh read a tweet is no
more evidence of anything than the fact that
Hitler breathing oxygen says anything about
oxygen.
More broadly, if you understand the point
that I'm making, alluding to an ad hominem
fallacy here.
And so we really gain nothing by scolding
people who are making what are honest critiques.
And we actually I would make the case lose
a lot when we do this tone policing and attempting
to regulate what counts as acceptable commentary.
And I was out of line, apparently, with what
is really a pretty milquetoast tweet, guys.
I mean, in the end, this tweet is nothing's
hinging on this tweet.
So I think it's interesting.
I don't know exactly how my tweet made it
to Rush Limbaugh.
Now, years ago, Rush Limbaugh did a whole
segment where he refers to this program and
a segment we did multiple times without calling
it by name.
And so we know that somehow, over time, clips
have gotten to Rush Limbaugh.
I don't know how this got to him, quite frankly,
but somehow it did.
But listen, if if you want a show that will
just always praise what the Democratic Party
is doing, I'm sure those shows exist.
It's just not this one.
OK.
And so I'm not apologizing and I will continue
to call it like it is August.
Twenty third is the 15th anniversary of the
David Pakman show.
We will be doing a huge membership special
if you want to be notified about it.
Just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
August twenty third e-mail.
We'll go out telling you how to take advantage
of what we hope will be the biggest single
day surge in memberships in David Pakman show
history.
And of course, remember that you can get the
podcast on any app you like Spotify, Stitcher,
Google, Play, I, iTunes, Pandora.
If that is your gig, get the daily audio podcast.
Take it with you every single day.